So today we're asking the question it's
her body her choice right we have the
right not to be mothers right 100 yeah
so yeah so I was about to say I'm got a
strong opinion about it because I don't
really want kids and I can just imagine
like how horrible it would be if you
don't have a choice to like do you know
I mean like get rid of the baby so the
question is should men have the right
then not to be fathers so if a woman
gets pregnant and he says I I want to
renounce paying child support would you
support that so he can sign off all of
his rights and leave it with the mother
yeah because we get the right to get rid
of the kid if we want shouldn't he have
the same right in the name of like
equality that's a tough one because I
guess it that would be fast
um because it's the same as the mum
giving up the child but then it's not
really in their body so I don't know how
different it is really so
um because the problem we're having is
it incentivizes women to get kids off of
Rich guys so for example the NBA has
issued statements telling players to
flush their condoms because girls will
steal them because they know if they get
a kid off of them they're entitled to
child support for 18 years oh he's sick
okay I didn't know that yeah and even
Drake I don't know if you heard about
when you put hot sauce in his condom I
don't know yeah the girl tried to swim
over it [__] that's that's crazy
actually yeah so it's like when we're
seeing things like that it begs the
question like should men have the right
not to be a father too and you would say
yeah 100 to be honest yeah okay okay
well we agree then thanks for stopping
a man a man who abandons his child as a
deadbeat dad correct
um not really there are like do you want
me to elaborate there there are like
many conditions that that allow for for
that to be to be possible and morally
permissible in in most cases
um it's to do with uh ties in a lot with
poverty
um but you know I don't know if the
label if that'd be that that is like
all-encompassing I think selective cases
maybe sorry I meant Society calls them a
deadbeat dad correct 100 I think that's
something that's yeah pretty well known
it's
so if a mother abandons her child why
don't and why do we call it the right to
choose well I don't really see that as
abandonment because because obviously
when when we're talking about the idea
of a deadbeat dad uh we're talking about
a child that's uh that's that's you know
uh been been born raised by a single
mother in in that instance
um but a woman abandoning her child
um that that's not referred to as as the
right to choose that's they're different
things if a woman left their child after
their child was born then if if they're
not being called out then you can you
can make that argument what about
adoption what what about adoption that's
also the right to choose right so I'm
saying like even if a woman gives up her
child we don't call her a deadbeat mom
even after it's born oh see sure sure
okay yeah so I'm asking why do you think
that is why do I think that is
um possibly because I think that there
needs to be uh more leniency uh on the
side of uh of women in in that regard
because I think think that uh
women who have to give their children up
for adoption is very different
circumstances in the majority of cases
from a man uh you know leaving the
leaving the family home or or divorcing
or separating well so I'm not why is it
different because I mean it could it
doesn't mean they were together if you
get pregnant right it just means they
were sleeping together so how is it
different if a man doesn't want to be a
father then if a woman doesn't want to
be a mother
because to me it's like it's the same
thing sure okay and and I'll I'll follow
that line of reasoning then so let's say
it is the same thing what what does that
insinuate for you what does insinuate
what do you mean so so you're saying
that uh you think it is the same thing
you think that they are equivalencies so
uh what what does that insinuate for you
what what does that lead on to is it do
you see that as a as a big problem that
they're viewed the same or do you see
that as the right thing do you see that
as not not very common that they're
viewed the same well I think women are
given passes for doing the same thing
that men do
there's a reason why why women are given
passes in areas where men where men
don't why because of a a precon
pre-existing uh privilege that men have
in in the majority of cases uh in life
in society how do men have a privilege
how do men have privilege when they're
the majority of suicides when they do
the majority of hard jobs they have to
fight in Wars
okay so so okay
I I think that if what you're asking and
what we're gonna have to talk about is
where men have privileges then we're not
going to be able to have this argument
with this this debate we're not going to
be able to talk about this because we're
just simply not on the same level of
understanding about society as a whole
if you're unable to understand that men
have privilege in the majority of cases
and that there is an underlying
privilege that all men have a by nature
of a patriarchy well I'm asking like
what what stats do you have to back that
up right so so I would say I would say
like man men also make up the majority
of homeless
so so how can you say that women have an
easier life
okay okay so what I just want to know
what what privilege are you talking
about okay I'll I'll talk about uh what
I mean by privilege I'm talking about um
an underlying uh uh societal
um condition that allows for for men to
to be paid more okay okay uh allows for
for men to to you know and you know we
talk about uh heinous crimes uh and
that's something that because of the
condition of men you see I I believe
that it's because of our economic State
okay men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime than women maybe not
a sexual violent crime not neither well
I think it goes underreported to be
honest both go under reported don't they
because women also don't report uh at
the same level uh that they that that is
the potential of of the amount of women
who've been abused that was
underreported as well doesn't it uh I
don't know I don't think I actually
might have a stat for that which is the
uh only one in three sexual assaults are
reported to the police
is it one of four or one in three women
are victims of uh
so they actually wouldn't
drunk and have sex in that step so no
that's what I'm saying so that they they
throw that stat around a lot and it's
not actually accurate I'm gonna uh I've
got my friends here from from Sweden I'm
gonna put an end to this because uh and
the reason I'm gonna say that okay is
that as I've said if you're unable to
understand the the the means at which
men are privileged in society over women
you're telling me I'm a press sorry are
you telling me I'm a press sorry you're
explaining my oppression to me do you
feel oppressed no okay well then it's
not an issue for you is it but there are
many women who do there's a lot of women
that don't are we talking globally here
are we talking what do you mean by that
well I know that I'm talking about the
Western World we're in England U.S okay
why why don't we take it global
why not talk because we're in the UK and
I'm from the US okay so in the US do you
feel that uh you you have
um the same uh allowances of privilege
than men I think I have more privilege
than most men yup
so so the statement means right women we
have the right if we get pregnant we
have the right not to be mothers right
yeah should men then in the name of
equality have the right not to be
fathers their wallet their choice they
can sign off on child support why no
because if you had sex with a woman you
fully know well that one of the
consequences is that you will fully like
pregnant her and you have a child so you
have to look after child as that's your
responsibility your sperm your
responsibility okay you can't run away
from that okay I don't understand why
people in their mind think it's all
right to run away from the child that's
a child you're leaving them with so much
trauma having no like Dad and everything
that will leave them with severe like
ideas of how they think about men
because